Now let's say you had a phobia of snakes, and your therapist going to use
systematic desensitization. First you learn the relaxation techniques, then
your therapist starts pairing the relaxation techniques with snake-related
stimuli. Now I want you to place the level of exposure you are about to see on
a hierarchy that you would expect therapist to use when gradually exposing you
to a snake. Seeing a picture of a snake in a terrarium, seeing a real snake in
a terrarium across the room. Holding a snake, seeing the word snake in print,
seeing a picture of someone holding a snake. Hearing the word snake, imagining
a snake, and seeing someone hold a snake from across the room. Write a letter
in each one of these boxes that goes from the least exposure, so the first
things that you'd be exposed to to get rid of your snake phobia, to the most
exposure. For example, this would be the last day of your therapy and you are
no longer scared of snakes.